While I'm sure you're really excited about entropy right now,
let's take this back to decision trees and
see how entropy actually affects how a decision tree draws its boundaries.
That involves a new piece of vocabulary, information gain.
Information gain is defined as the entropy of the parent
minus the weighted average of the entropy of the children that
would result if you split that parent.
The decision tree algorithm will maximize information gain.
So this is how it will choose which feature to make a split on.
And in cases where the feature has many different values that it can take,
this will help it figure out where to make that split.
It is going to try to maximize the information gain.
Let's do an example.